foreign
[Music]
gator boots have been worn for about 10
years the friction of wear has created a
hole in the toe area
they will be restored by unsung calves
the Tennessee shoe repair shop that
specializes in restoring cowboy boots
a cobbler removes the heel block and
outsole using Nipper pliers and a round
Point leather working knife
then he cuts off the boots gemming since
it will be replaced later
he patches the hole in the boot's toe
area using a special glue and a piece of
leather
which he stands to comfortably blend
into the shoe
a new jamming is glued on
then he sews it in for added security
a new leather welt goes over the jamming
this creates a layer to attach the
uppers to the outsole
the cobbler then Cuts glues and hammers
in new cork midsoles
the cork is grated
glued
and attached to the new outsole
uses two machines to finish the outsole
one cuts the excess sole none other sews
a good year well
then the soles are sanded and dyed
[Music]
to finish the restoration he attaches
the heel block with glue and nails
once the heels are dyed to match the
rest of the sole the boots are given a
final polish
[Music]
after a year of heavy wear these
Birkenstock soles have worn out exposing
the cork footbed causing serious damage
to repair them ryukim starts by removing
the foam outsole at the knife
he cuts rather than peels the soles
apart to avoid damaging the core footbed
further
he applies glue in the crevice of the
cracked Cork and squeezes the joints
together for one minute while the glue
dries
for the shoe with the damaged heel Rio
trims cork footboard to fit the area
then secures it with glue
he shapes the cork with a sander and 40
grit sandpaper
then he uses the old outsole to create a
pattern for the new ones and roughly
Cuts them out
Rio Sands the foam outsoles and bottoms
of the shoes to even out the surface
this creates a clean canvas and helps
the glue stick
he applies glue to the shoe bottom and
the foam outsole
then bends the outsole so it fits the
curved footbed comfortably
the body of the shoes and outsole are
then pressed together and Rio cuts the
excess off
foreign
the last step is sanding the sole to
shape and applying sealant to the cork
footbeds
these well-loved LL Bean boots are now
Torn Between the sole and upper they
were mailed back to the LL Bean Factory
for resolving
a special machine deconstructs the boots
by sawing the outsoles apart from the
uppers
a technician then strips the boots of
the remaining brush guard using scissors
and a flat knife
the remaining stitches will be
individually plucked off the uppers by
hand a rub machine with rotating
bristles loosens the stitches and makes
the work easier
with the stitches removed the boots can
be reassembled cement is applied to the
Booth's new Sole and the upper
then the soles and uppers are attached
to finish a vamping machine drops three
rows of stitches to secure the uppers to
the sole
after these Louboutin loafers were worn
in the Rain the paint at the bottom
bubbled to restore the trademark red
bottoms Sunny applies a rubber
protective sole
he starts by deciding where the new
protective souls and original Souls will
meet he tapes a guide then uses a knife
to skeeve an end joint this is where the
new thicker protective sole will blend
into the original he follows the same
process and the shoe's heels
then he Sands the soles and heels to
remove their paint and even out the
surface
Sunny applies glue to the bottom of the
shoe and the new protective soles
[Music]
the soles and shoe body are then pressed
together
he trims the excess sole then Sands it
to the shape of the shoe
to finish he dresses the edges and
polishes the shoe
these Air Jordan 11s are from 1996 and
have yellowed with age
to repair the discoloration Richard
Brown deconstructs the shoe
he peels the soles apart from one
another by hand
when the outsoles are removed he
separates the midsole from the upper of
the shoe
he deoxidizes the outsoles using
ultraviolet light and 40 volume green a
gel lightener
this repairs the soles yellowing
then he removes old glue from the
outsole midsole
and bottom of the shoe using a rotary
tool an acetone
[Music]
the outsoles midsoles and uppers are
reattached using a special glue
formulated for sneaker repair